foreign
by frustration anger and a need to speak
out thousands of Sri Lankans from
different communities faiths and
backgrounds came together in Colombo
they demanded an end to the government's
oppression of peaceful protests against
the economic crisis
it's brought the country to a near
standstill and left people struggling to
get by activist Joseph Stalin is free on
bail after being charged in four
different cases related to taking part
in protests
[Music]
people can't live the cost of things are
three times out of people's salaries
Farmers laborers fishermen can't survive
the government wants to stop people
taking to the streets that is what this
repression is about
[Music]
other demonstrators say they want the
government to stop using terrorist laws
against protesters and to repeal the
prevention of terrorism act the PTA was
used against these two student leaders
who've spent more than 10 weeks in
detention the crowds want them released
police wrote to protest leaders warning
of legal action and they were out in
force to stop the March tempers fled
from elephants come to uh railway
station but what look what they're doing
this is not that right I must say this
is your this is the end this is the end
protesters say President Ronald Vikram
singha was elected by parliamentarians
but has no mandate they accuse him of
being a proxy for the rajapaksa family
who were forced out of office earlier
this year I am not angry with them
I am frustrated
I want to change this situation these
are scenes the Government tried hard to
avoid claiming they would deter
investors and scare away tourists when
it's trying to rebuild the economy the
tourist industry and business Community
echoed that view
the Human Rights Commission has warned
the police that people's right to
express themselves must be respected
it's an absolute free-for-all on the
streets of Colombo as thousands of
people get onto the streets to voice
their frustration they say despite
government assurances that things are on
the mend it certainly feels different
day-to-day Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo